لقد تحدثت أنا وأنت عن هذا قليلاً
عندما كنا في أوكرانيا ولكني أردت
الاتصال لأنها المرة الأولى التي
أنجب فيها أطفالًا وسافر مع هذا القدر
من الوقت ومن الواضح أن لديك
طفلان وكذلك كم عمرك  هل أطفالك الذين
يبلغون من العمر أربعة أعوام ونصف ، يتعامل الكثير من الآباء
مع السفر ، من الواضح أنك
تسافر إلى
مناطق حرب في أماكن معقدة للغاية ، لكن
كيف تتعامل مع ذلك بصفتك أحد الوالدين
بصراحة ،
أعتقد أنني ما زلت أعمل
عليه  من
الصعب حقًا أن يكون الأمر صعبًا حقًا وأي شخص يقول
أنه ليس كذلك هو
أنك تعرف
إما أن تكون قد عملت على شيء ما
لم أعمل عليه بعد
أو أنهم
يكذبون لأنني أشعر بالذنب
كوالد مع كونك بعيدًا عن
أطفالك حتى  إذا كنت تعرف أن ذلك لأسباب وجيهة
وحتى إذا كنت تعلم أنك تشعر
بالثقة
إلى حد كبير ، فسيكونون سعداء على المدى الطويل لأنك
قمت بالعمل الذي قمت به وما إلى ذلك ،
وما ساعدني هو مثل
بناء هذه الحياة لأولادي
الموجود بدوني فيه أيضًا ، لذا فأنا
أمتلك  زوج رائع حاضر جدًا
ولداي مربيتان قويتان جميلتان بشكل لا يصدق
يحبانك ،
وربما
أكثر مني وهو عبارة عن
سكين في قلبي أحيانًا ولكن في الغالب
أنا مثلك تعرف ما هي أفضل
هدية يمكنني الحصول عليها  اسأل دائمًا عن
والديّ حاضرين
حقًا ، وأعتقد أن الطريقة الوحيدة التي
يمكنك القيام بها هي أن تجتمع معًا وأن
تبني
جيشك وتتأكد من أن أطفالك
يتمتعون بحياة آمنة سعيدة سعيدة
وأنهم يقومون بالفرز  التعود
على فكرة أنك تعرف سفر والدك أو والدك في
بعض الأحيان ،
وهذا لا يعني أن هناك شيئًا خاطئًا أو
أي شيء سيء ونتحدث في فيس تايم
كل يوم على الرغم من أنني لا أعرف كيف
عثرت على شيء فيس تايم ، يكون من الصعب جدًا
عندما  إنهم صغار
حقًا ، لقد وجدت الأمر صعبًا جدًا
لأن ابني الأكبر يكاد يكون أكثر من اللازم ،
أنت تعلم
أنه كان
مهتمًا أكثر بالمكنسة
الكهربائية التي اعتقد أنها كانت في غرفتي
والتي كانت في الواقع عبارة عن lig  ht هذا وهكذا
عندما سأفعل عندما
يراني ، فإن أول شيء سيقوله هو
كلمته عن المكنسة الكهربائية وهي kakalo
التي لا أعرف لماذا هذه هي كلمته
عن المكنسة الكهربائية ولكنها لم تكن مثل
أبيها  كان
مكنسة كهربائية وكان علي أن أظهر
له الضوء
الذي كان مهتمًا به حقًا
مقارنة بي والذي يجب أن أقول أنه جعلني
أشعر بأنني شعرت بنوع من الرعب ، أعني أنني
أحببت رؤيته ولكنه جعل الأمر أكثر صعوبة
تقريبًا وهو مضحك  يجب أن تقول
ذلك لأننا كنا نفعل
مثل وقت الوجه أثناء وقت الاستحمام
والأشياء وأحيانًا
كنت أرغب في إنهاء البرد ليس لأنني
لا أريد أن أنظر إلى أطفالي الجميلين
ولكن لأنه
أصبح مؤلمًا جدًا
في بعض الأحيان  نقطة وعندما
تعمل بشكل خاص في منطقة نزاع ،
فأنت تحاول حقًا التقسيم
إلى أقصى حد ممكن وأن
تحافظ على طاقتك ومزاجك نوعًا ما
في اتجاه معين
وإذا سمحت لنفسك بالذهاب
بعيدًا  تختلف  ر الفضاء مساحة محبة مفتوحة أكثر ضعفًا بكثير ،
فأنت تشعر فجأة بكل المشاعر
وكأنها غامرة قليلاً تقريبًا
[موسيقى]